foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones update
video in this video I will be discussing
some very exciting news regarding one of
the most beloved characters in all of
Game of Thrones and even A Song of Ice
and Fire now in a recent interview Sean
Bean who we all know and love is Ned
Stark said he would be very interested
in returning for another Game of Thrones
series this is significant because I
believe the likelihood of this happening
is actually very high as you all know
HBO is already working on a show that
would be very fitting for a Ned Stark
reunion now before I show you exactly
what I mean I have to let all of you
know about this amazing new animated
series I'd like to thank the sponsor of
today's video raid Shadow Legends raid
Shadow Legends is getting its very own
animated series called raid call of the
Arbiter just like everyone's favorite
game The Limited animated series is set
in the dark fantasy world of taleria
this series will consist of 10 5-minute
episodes all releasing on Thursdays 10
a.m Eastern Standard time between May
18th and July 20th raid call of the
Arbiter is available to watch for free
and raid Shadow Legends right now giving
fans what they've been asking for for
years which is more backstory lore and a
glimpse into the wider world of the
game's setting raid is also doing a ton
of cool player friendly events and
content drops to celebrate there are 75
new character lore bios in in-game
events and the chance to get one of the
characters from the show as a playable
legendary champion for free through
their 7 Day loyalty program now let me
be the first to say the animation is
incredible the characters and their
weapons are awesome and the music scored
by Jasper kid is my favorite part raid
isn't just another gaming app this
limited animated series takes the story
and the world to a whole new level I was
so pleasantly surprised at how immersive
it was when I finally got to watch that
first episode now I know you all love
Dark Fantasy as much as I do so take my
word for it you will not regret watching
this after you've watched check out the
new Call of the Orbiter related features
in the game everyone will get the chance
to get our one of the five new
characters from the show as a playable
legendary champion for free just by
logging into raid for seven days between
now and July 24th if you haven't started
playing rage yet go to my link in the
description or scan the QR code on the
screen to get a free starter pack with
this cool end game Loot and as always
you can find me in game under my name
talking Thrones I look forward to seeing
you all there once again I have to give
a huge thank you to raid for sponsoring
today's video
all right now let me show you what Sean
Bean actually said during a recent
exclusive interview Sean Bean opened up
about him returning to Game of Thrones
after confessing he has yet to watch
House of the Dragon the actor confirmed
he would be interested in showing up
again as Ned Stark if the opportunity
presented itself he said I don't know if
he'd ever be incorporated again I'm not
that clued up about the following for
House of the Dragon I've heard it's
really good I'm gonna try to see that
eventually but yeah it's always nice to
think that you could be involved in some
way in such a great series something
that became worldwide I don't think at
the time we knew with Lord of the Rings
how big that was gonna turn out and it
was the same with Game of Thrones if I'm
ever asked again it would be nice to be
involved in some way well ladies and
gentlemen that's about as official as it
gets not only did he say he would love
to come back to Game of Thrones again
but he even said he would do it as Ned
Stark one of the greatest characters
ever created if you ask me now some of
you might be wondering how the hell
would this work as we all know Ned is
dead not only that that but Ned has no
head well believe it or not we could
actually see Ned Stark again in the new
Jon Snow show now remember my friends
just because Sean Bean made it official
doesn't mean HBO has if this is
something you would like to see make
sure you let HBO know down below they
are watching and they will need to know
if this is something the fans would like
to see now let me show you what screen
rain had to say about this because I
think they described it exactly how HBO
could get it done it basically lines up
with what I was already thinking in
their recent article they said Game of
Thrones has one genius way to bring back
Ned Stark actor Sean Bean has already
shown interest in playing Ned Stark
again as HBO developed several Game of
Thrones shows and there's a smart way to
make it happen now as we all know Ned
Stark isn't alive during House of the
dragon or a knight of the Seven Kingdoms
the Hedge Knight but he could appear in
the Game of Thrones sequel about Jon
Snow now yes it's true that Ned isn't
alive in that particular timeline either
obviously Ned died during the first
season in the new Jon Snow show will
show us what happens with Jon Snow after
the events of Game of Thrones when Ned
is no longer alive however we could see
Ned Stark again via flashbacks or dreams
in the Jon Snow show that would make
sense not a lot is known about the
sequel's story but it needs to address
Jon Snow's Targaryen Heritage more than
Game of Thrones did and reflect on all
the trauma he now has Ned Stark would
fit in nicely with that it was after all
Ned who made the decision to raise Jon
as his own son in order to keep a
promise to his sister lyanna that would
be a secret he would take to his grave
indeed the last time John saw Ned Stark
he said he would tell him about his
mother when they saw each other again
Jon thinking back to his time with Ned
while simultaneously struggling with the
weight of his actions and killing
Daenerys Targaryen and whether it was
the right honorable Choice something Ned
instilled in him more than anyone could
mean revisiting their old conversations
he could look to his father for guidance
or be haunted by the dreams of him
allowing Ned to return one last time now
there's obviously a risk involved
because his death was so good and it
would be unwise to harm that moment but
the flashbacks or dreams wouldn't do so
if Done Right much of the mystery around
Jon was about his mom and dad but as we
all know Ned was his true father the one
who really shaped him as the man we all
grew to love now seeing how Jon scarred
by trauma and loss reflects upon his
legacy and whether he did right by Ned
while at the same time questioning Ned's
own choices could allow for some
emotional and introspective flashbacks
or dreams it would add more context and
way to their relationship and John's
lineage now I fully agree with what this
article says I believe it would make for
an amazing moment in the Jon Snow series
we already know HBO has been working on
this show with kit Harrington and now
that we know Sean Bean is interested in
coming back as Ned Stark I think we very
well could see it happen after all he's
not the first Game of Thrones veteran
who said they would love to revisit
Westeros all the excitement around the
Jon Snow show has revealed there are a
lot of other Game of Thrones actors
ready to step back into their legendary
characters once again now I have said it
once and I will say it again Dear Mr HBO
I think I speak for a lot of fans when I
say we definitely want to see this
happen imagine if they actually released
a new trailer where we saw Jon Snow and
ghost making their way back south of the
wall then we see a shot of Sansa sitting
out under the werewood in winterfell's
godswood then it cuts to Arya sailing
back to Westeros while also showing Bran
Stark sitting on a new Iron Throne only
this one is made of werewood and the
branches are all twisted around his body
like the three odd Ravens while showing
all of this we could hear that amazing
soundtrack from the original Game of
Thrones then right before it ends it
phases a black and we hear Ned Stark's
voice I get excited just thinking about
how amazing it could be let me know what
all of you think down below what are
your thoughts about Ned Stark showing up
in the Jon Snow show in some form or
fashion as always I have to thank all of
you for watching another video I hope
you all have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
thank you